-Melanie, Dave,
nice to meet you,
and thank you for
coming on our show.
We appreciate this.
-Thanks for having us.
This is awesome.
-I'm so happy to be here.
In America.
-Yes, in America. Yes.
Well, "Bluey" is one of the,
I think, one of the most --
It's the best show on TV
right now, "Bluey."
I mean, there's "Tonight Show."
-Did you hear that?
-I did hear that. And who are
your favorite characters?
-Oh, yeah, well, of course
Bandit and Chilli,
of course, my favorite.
Better than Bluey and Bingo,
of course.
But I think the show is --
It's so funny.
It's clever.
It's game changing.
I think -- I love it so much.
I've seen more of you guys
and heard more of your voices
than I've heard my own voice
in my household.
And the kids aren't even
watching.
It's just me watching this.
Yeah.
Melanie, how did you end up
getting the role?
-It was actually quite a
serendipitous situation.
I was putting a voice-over down
with Joe's brother, Dan,
who works on the show.
He plays Stripe.
-And Joe created --
-Joe created the show.
-Yeah.
-And he said, "My brother's
creating this animation.
You've got a great voice.
Do you want to work some
voice-overs down?
It's already cast, but maybe in
the future."
Anyway so, at the 11th hour, ABC
decided to change up the voices.
I had already seen the pilot,
and I had fallen in love.
Like, the most cute --
Like, my heart hurts.
This is so cute show.
So I'm like,
"Yes, use anything."
And then they did their due
diligence and auditioned for
like three months and then came
back and said,
"No, you were right."
And a year later, the producers
told me that they couldn't find
the same warmth
from anyone else.
-Hey. You'll take that.
[ Audience aws ]
Come on, see. And they were
right. They're correct.
Dave?
-Yeah.
-How did you get this?
-Well --
[ Laughter ]
I was walking out of a lift
and someone was walking --
Someone I knew was walking into
the lift and they said,
"I know someone who's making a
show about a cartoon dog family.
Maybe you'd want to be
the dad voice?"
And I was like, "I can't act.
I can't do that."
And he said, "Can you read?"
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Well...
I can read a bit."
[ Laughter ]
And so they gave me, you know,
a script with highlighted bits
of where I got to say stuff.
So I started reading
and we just kept going.
And then we sort of had
done a pilot.
And then I thought,
"Oh, this will be nice.
This will be on YouTube
as some sort of,
one-off, you know,
short animation."
And then here we are.
Bigger than the Beatles.
[ Laughter ]
-"Bluey" is bigger than
the Beatles, yeah.
And you guys, you were telling
me backstage
you just met each other --
-Two days ago?
-Two days ago,
for the first time.
-So, I'm sorry, how?
-So, we record separately.
-Yeah.
-We live in different cities,
and I travel a lot for work.
So, this was the first time.
-How cool is that?
-It was wild. In New York.
-I know. I thought it would be
all of us sitting
around a table, you know,
like in the movies when
they're making a TV show.
-Yeah.
-And everyone is sitting around
the table with coffee
and salads and rolls and stuff.
But we're just isolated
in our booths.
-Yeah.
-You have young kids.
What do they think of their dad
voicing Bandit?
-They love it. Rose and Grace.
They're now --
Grace is almost 9. Rose is 11.
They love it.
They were confused when it first
came on TV because they'd look
at the TV and Bandit speaking
and look at me and look at the
TV and like, "What's going on?"
-Yeah, it's so hard to tell
a kid what --
-It's a connection, isn't it?
-Yeah, it's wild.
'Cause now when you talk,
all I see is the cartoon.
-I know. It's weird when parents
say, "Come and meet my kid.
They love the show."
I'm like, "Oh, don't.
They normally burst into tears."
[ Laughter ]
Because they think
I've, like, eaten Bandit
and his voice is coming out.
[ Laughter ]
-They don't understand it, yeah.
-And they, "Go on, do the
voice." "Hey, how you doing?"
-But you really just sound
like Bandit.
-"He's doing the voice! Oh, my
God, he's doing the voice!"
-It is my voice, yeah.
I should also mention, by
the way, "Bluey's Big Play" is
a show, a live "Bluey" show
that was just at
Madison Square Garden
that I just missed.
I'm like, oh, my gosh.
But I'm sure
it'll come back around.
But it's a giant phenomenon now,
"Bluey."
In fact, also it is a balloon
in the Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade.
-Yeah.
-Now, is that a big --
Do you know what that is
in Australia?
-Well, it was explained to me
from friends in L.A.
just, like, how monumental
that is.
Because I was like, "Oh, we have
some float in a parade."
-Yeah, there's a balloon
somewhere.
-It's Thanksgiving.
Is it a thing?
-It's a massive deal.
-And people are like,
"It's a thing!"
-It's a massive deal
to have a balloon, yeah.
You have a Bluey balloon.
That's so cool.
It's going to be unbelievable.
It's going to be --
Congrats on that.
I'm just so happy that you guys
are here and came on the show.
I'm the biggest fan of the show.
I want to see a "Bluey" movie,
by the way.
-Sure.
-I'd like to see a "Bluey"
movie.
-A trilogy.
-Yes. Make a trilogy.
-The pre-story one.
-Let's start with a trilogy.
Yeah, exactly. Very smart, Dave.
I want to show everyone a clip
from the show.
Here are Dave McCormack and
Melanie Zanetti in "Bluey."
Take a look a this.
-Check it out, Mum.
-Hey, nice strategy,
balloon girls.
-I'm a keepie-uppie expert.
-Yeah. But it's not as fun now.
Can you make it hard again?
-Sorry, pickle.
I've got my hands full.
-♪ Oh, good morning, everybody ♪
♪ I said good morning,
everyone ♪
Unh. What up, party people?
-Dad, we're playing
keepie-uppie.
Can you make it harder?
-Ah, my newspaper.
-Dad!
-Bingo, help!
-I can't. I'm a newspaper!
[ Giggles ]
-Oh, I love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's such a great show.
I love it, love it,
love it so much.
Dave McCormack and
Melanie Zanetti, everybody.
You can watch "Bluey"
on Disney Jr. and Disney+.
Got to blueylive.com for more
info on "Bluey's Big Play."